foreign
[Silence]
tonight we are continuing
the entire name of the book is
it's a rhyming name
and this book has been authored by
the great and esteemed sheikh of islam
even
is one of the greater scholars of the
eighth century after hijrah
now we've mentioned a lot of accolades
regarding this book
the names
basically tells the entire story
what is the subject of the book
well the translation of this
name of this title of the book is
provisions
that are taken for the great
appointment
provisions taken from the ways and
traditions of the best of mankind
this is all taken from the statement of
allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala in surat
al-baqarah
what is
take provisions for your journey
and the best of provisions to be taken
is the provisions of piety for the
greater journey
so all of us are on a journey to allah
subhanahu wa
just as when you get ready to go on a
journey you get ready to go on a trip
you get ready to travel
you take provisions for yourself
now those provisions are whatever are is
appropriate whether it be cash or
travelers checks or cards or whatever it
is
you take provisions
back in the time of the prophet
salallahu alaihi wasallam you'd have to
carry your own food with you you'd have
to carry your own water with you
alhamdulillah these amenities are
plentiful in our time so
so our provisions are different
so any time you take a journey you have
to have provisions you have to prepare
yourself you have to pack your stuff
to get ready to go on this journey
well we are all on a greater journey
and that is a journey to allah
allah subhanahu says
o human being
indeed you are working and toiling
and
going towards the meeting of your lord
and indeed you are going to meet him
so we're all on a journey
we're traveling
it may not seem we're traveling
but we really are
every single breath we take is a step in
a direction towards our meeting with
allah subhanahu wa
every time our heart beats and pumps
that is another step
towards allah subhanahu wa
every single one of us
has a certain amount of steps that he
has been given by allah
you have a number of breaths that you
have been given
you have a number of beats that your
heart has been allowed to to beat
you have a number of days number of
sunsets and a number of sunrises that
you will be privy to
when that number is concluded you will
now transition from this life into the
hereafter
and that is our great journey our great
journey is from this earth
to our final abode whatever that is
whether that be the abode of paradise
may allah subhanahu wa ta'ala make it
our abode
or it be the abode of hellfire
but either way we are on a journey to
our final abode
wrote this book
as
a source of provisions for that greater
journey
what does that mean
we are preparing ourselves
for our journey to allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala
what is that preparation taken from
it is taken from the sunnah of the
prophet
the prophet muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
he is the one who has walked the path
of enlightenment ahead of us
every prophet and messenger
has been sent with the same message
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
he said we the prophets are maternal
we the prophets are paternal
brothers
our mothers are different yet our
religion is the same
so what does that mean
that means that every single prophet
came with the same general message what
is that message
two things
worship allah alone without any partners
worship allah only in the way that i
teach you muhammad rasulullah
that is the that is the message of every
prophet and messenger
they came to teach us these two main
things
they came to teach us who to worship
and they came to teach us
how
to worship
and so
he is essentially alluding to the fact
that
a prophet a messenger the best of
mankind
even the prophet muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
the one who has been given the great
intercession
the one who has been given the greatest
accolades and the greatest book
even
the best of mankind the greatest of
allah's
creation he
is only responsible for himself
right
he cannot bear the sins of anyone else
we do not have a savior in the sense of
someone who will walk the path for us
every single one of us has to walk his
own path
the prophets the messengers the prophet
he came to teach us
what the path is
he came to teach us how the path looks
what to avoid what to look for who to be
around who to stay away from etc that's
what he came for
he even walked the path ahead of us so
that we can see him and follow his every
step
but he cannot walk the path for us
we have to do that
every one of us is responsible for his
own salvation
right
and so ibn al-qayyim is saying this book
is provisions for the hereafter for the
great meeting
why
because you are taking your provisions
of piety
from the ways and traditions and sunan
and legacy of the best of mankind
[Arabic recitation]
that's the subject of this book
so what does this book mention
this book mentions everything about the
prophet salallahu
everything
everything that the
author could have possibly
thought of
and what's amazing about this book if
you notice here
the thickness of this book this is about
a 250 page book
this is not the original book
the original book written by abdul
kaiyum is five volumes
it exceeds 3 000 pages
now that's impressive right
but what's more impressive
is that he wrote it completely from
memory
that's what's really impressive why is
that impressive
well ibn kayim went to hajj
okay this is the story of this book
he went to hajj
and in those times
a person didn't just take a plane and go
to hedge take off work for two weeks and
come back that's not how hajj was
hajj was a year-long thing
sometimes it would take six months to
get there just the traveling
you make your hajj and then it would
take six months to get back you would be
gone for
sometimes an entire year
and so what ibn kayem did is he decided
that on my way to hajj
and on my return he made hajj once
i'm going to write a book about the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
right
and he named this book zadil ma'ad
and so he wrote this book
from memory
and that's why the book
doesn't seem to be in complete order
right
he doesn't mention it
in exact precise order sometimes it's a
little bit scattered
but that's because he wrote it from
memory it's almost a journal
right
but what's amazing is that he quoted
more than 200 sources
verbatim meaning word for word
from memory
and wrote more than 3 000 pages all
about the prophet sallallahu alaihi
there is almost not a single sunnah that
he missed
in this book
everything about him how he walked how
he spoke how he sat
how he would
address the people how he prayed how he
made hajj how he fasted how he
we have we ever heard of the book
the prophet's medicine
the prophet's medicine it's a famous
book right that's actually the fourth
volume of zadil
it's not an independent book
right that's part of zadil mahad
and so
in the first two volumes
he spoke about the five pillars of islam
everything having to do with
salah
hajj
fasting exactly how the prophet
sallallahu alaihi
those are the first two volumes
the third volume is his life story his
biography
from the moment he received revelation
until he passed away
sallallahu the fourth volume is all
about the medicine of the prophet
salallahu
everything that had to do with any
ailment
whether it be
psychological whether it be spiritual or
whether it be physical
anything that he addressed with regards
to medicine
with regards to curing
with regards to addressing any ailment
that is what the fourth volume is about
the fifth volume of z
is about his judgments
any time people came with a dispute any
issue that happened
the hadood
cutting off the hand of the thief and
the
penalty for murder and all of these
different things
everything that he ever judged is in the
fifth volume of zed al-mahd so zad
al-ma'ad is an extremely
dense book
right it's a very dense book
and it's a book that
since it was written
is considered to be a reference for
everyone that came after
who spoke about the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
he did incredible things in this book he
took narrations he took things that
seemed to be contradicting and he
harmonized them and he made all of the
sunnah into one
very
beautiful and elegant picture
this is why zed almaad is so important
it's a very important book in the
islamic library and unfortunately it's
very unknown it's not
it's pretty obscure most most people
don't know about it the average muslim
doesn't really know much about zadil
which is a tragedy
because
is one of the most crucial and pivotal
books with regards to the son of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam ever
written in the islamic library
we
spoke about
last week and the week before
we discussed
how the prophet salallahu alaihi
wasallam would go to visit the ill
anybody who is ill anybody who is sick
how he would visit them now is
transitions into
speaking about
the dead how the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam would deal with death
so
as soon as somebody gets
sick or is
becomes ailing of anything
we see that the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam and his sunna and his
companions are there
all the way until a person passes away
and is buried
and even after that
the right of the muslim upon his brother
is not ended there
there are still rights that continue on
past death which we will discuss
inshallah
we'll read here he says
[Silence]
he says
that it is of the sunnah of the prophet
sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
that
an individual
when he passes away
we should hasten the preparation of the
body
we shouldn't delay
right
we should not delay
the preparation of the body
rather the body should be taken
as immediately as possible
it should be bathed it should be cleaned
it should be perfumed
right
and it should be shrouded
preferably in white shrouds
the way that the prophet salallahu
alaihi wasallam was shrouded
is he was shrouded in three shrouds
one of which had pinstripes on it all of
them were white
one of these
shrouds had pinstripes
that is preferable
right
but any shroud will do of any color
is fine
it doesn't have to be exactly that
as long as the body is shrouded right
this is part of the
part of the ritual of the
muslim in shrouding the body
now the body should be bathed
the body should be bathed and the way
usually that the bathing of the body
takes place
is that the
exact same way that we make ghosts
the way that the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam used to make russell
is the way that the body should be
bathed and prepared
so what does that mean
well we begin with the private parts
right
some of the scholars mentioned pressing
lightly on the stomach to
push out any
excrement or anything that could come
out and stain the shroud right a light
push to empty out the bladder to empty
out the bowels right
that should be clean
we make
for the person
well
the mouth you take a rag and you clean
the teeth and you clean the
mouth you clean the inside of the nose
and you wash the face and the arms and
you wash the
wipe over the head and you wash the feet
after that you begin to bathe the body
starting on the right side so you bathe
the right side of the body and then you
bathe the left side of the body
after you have completed this process
you then begin to shroud the body
and put perfume on the body
right
there is also something called
attachment
is to use
a particular type of perfume
which
honestly is used mainly to keep away the
bugs and so forth it's something that is
revolting to
insects and stuff
but it's not necessary what's important
is
to put some kind of perfume that is all
fine
if we are bathing a woman
it is the sunnah of the prophet
salallahu alaihi wasallam
that
the hair be braided
that the hair of the woman
be braided
now
as the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam's daughter's hair
was braided when she passed away
it was actually braided in three braids
as is in sahih muslim
also
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
would use the lotus leaf
the lotus leaf
he would crush it up and put it in the
water
what is the reason for that well that is
it has a cleaning
it's soap
right
do we need to do that now
you can
but soap will suffice right
just we see in the sunnah where the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam says
to use dirt
when you're cleaning right
that's because they didn't have soap at
the time
if a person uses soap
in cleaning now
they have performed the sunnah you
didn't have to use the lotus leaf in
order to have performed the sunnah
another example
when we're cleaning our teeth
do we have to use a miswak
from the arak tree in order to perform
the sunnah
you know the miswac that's sold in the
do we have to use that
for it to be the sunnah the answer is no
what's important is cleaning the teeth
this is what they used to use in the
time of the prophet
if you use that that's great but a
toothbrush will suffice
right when you use your toothbrush
with or without toothpaste you are
performing the sunnah of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
it's important for us to understand
the reasons behind
why the prophet salallahu alaihi
wasallam chose to use certain things
many of those reasons is because there
wasn't anything else accessible at the
time
right the lotus leaf when you crush it
up and you put it in water
it becomes a cleaning agent it
helps to clean
right likewise dirt
it helps to clean well the same thing
can be said for arm and hammer the same
thing can be said for
irish spring soap the same thing can be
said for all of these things right
and so
this is how the prophet salallahu alaihi
wasallam would prepare the body at first
he would prepare everybody
anyone who would die he would prepare it
but the companions
quickly learned
how to prepare the body
and they saw that it was a great burden
for the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam to
every single time drop what he's doing
and prepare the body
and so each tribe
began to designate people to prepare the
body
and they would bring the body to the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam only
for prayer
right so at the beginning he would
prepare everybody he would bathe
everybody
but
later on the companions learned
and so they would prepare their own body
let's say the tribe of
whatever tribe right from an oath or
al-khazraj or what have you right from
darba naja would pass away
well they would have someone bathe the
body and prepare the body and then they
would merely bring the body to the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
prepared
right and then he would make salah over
the body
i want to mention something about the
salah
the prayer the funeral prayer
every time
there is an innovation
the sunnah will
be absent
innovation and sunnah are two opposites
it's day and night
when one is present the other is absent
okay
so
a lot of times
we see that people stand to make dua
right
for a really long time and they want to
read quran and they want to give
eulogies and they want to do all this
stuff
and so sometimes i've been to funerals
right
where
alhamdulillah it's not that here in
this masjid
but i've been to funerals elsewhere and
outside of this country
where it's basically an entire program
right you have a host
a master of so you know a master of
ceremonies
and
first we have his friend who used to
grow up with him and they used to you
know run around and and play with
marbles together and he'll come up and
he'll talk about how great a guy he was
and blah blah blah and then we'll have
potted so and so come and recite
suratiya
and then we have so and so come up and
give a big long lengthy dua and then
we have so and so come up and give us a
big long lecture about death and so
on and so forth and then finally after
all of that
sometimes up to an hour right then we
have salat
[Arabic recitation]
two minutes and it's over right
this is exactly the opposite of how
things should be
i remember i went to a funeral once
where they had this kind of thing going
on it was a long ceremony right
big long thing
hundreds of people were present
okay
and then after all of this
when it came time to make the salah
itself
the host or the announcer said hurry up
hurry up we don't have much time we have
people need to leave and so forth
he was so fast i couldn't even recite
surat al-fatiha
right
this is
the opposite
is what benefits the person who's passed
away
that's the that's the crux of it that's
where the rubber meets the road
that's a person's final rights
we stand and make solatil
in the narration of
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
in
[Silence]
no person will pass away
and then
100 people
and in another narration 40 people
will stand
and make salah upon him these people
have pure hearts they do not associate
any partners unto allah
except that allah will grant them
intercession on his behalf
right
this is what salatel geneza is for
when we stand to make swallowtail
janazah what is salah
well salatul janaza is for techbird
right
we make the first tech beer and we
recite surat al-fatiha
subhanallah
is referred to as the opening chapter
it's as if it opens a door between the
servant and allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
it's referred to as the opening chapter
no prayer is complete without
al-fatiha
the prophet
is valid
listen to this narration
and imagine this when you are in your
prayer
in sahih muslim abu hurairah narrates
that the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said
[Silence]
subscribe
abdi
[Silence]
because it is the opening chapter
it is as if it
unveils it removes a veil between us and
allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
imagine yourself going to meet the king
and there are certain words that have to
be said and a certain ceremony that you
have to go through in order to be
allowed into the court
of the king
the judge the king of kings subhanahu
wata'ala and that is surat
and so
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
said
no salah can be valid
which surat al-fatiha has not been
recited in
you have to recite surah
so look how
look at the
the
compelling way
the incredible way
that allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala has
structured
i know here at this masjid we have a lot
of solateal genes right
almost every other day we have salih
and sometimes
when we have a lot of something we start
to kind of take it for granted you know
what i mean
but if you really think about it
if you really imagine that this person
that has passed away
one day was a young child who made his
mother smile
one day was
a young man who had aspirations
or a young woman
one day had thoughts and dreams and a
person
an entire story
that has now ended
right
each
each time we make salah janazah it is
special
it is different it's a different person
and i'm a different person
and so when we look at the way that
allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has
it is
amazing
we begin with surat al-fatiha
almost as if to
reach out and begin our communication
with allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
[Arabic recitation]
akbar
what comes after the second tech beer
a salad upon the prophet salallahu
right
allah
[Silence]
just as we do in traditional prayer
after tashahud
now why is it that we make salah here
upon the prophet
who said something very interesting
[Silence]
will remain stagnant
between the heavens and the earth
until you make salah upon the
and the scholars mention that the best
way is when a person wishes to make dua
they make dua
starting with praising allah
and then making a salah upon the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam and then they
make their dua
if they make their dua
and then make a salah upon the prophet
alaihi wasallam at the end of the dua it
will suffice
but it's not the best
the best is to start
with us upon the prophet sallallahu
alaihi
mahji
so
the second part of
janazah
is that we are making a salah upon the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam this
is so that our dua will be accepted on
behalf of this person
so
[Silence]
foreign
inshallah
[Silence]
allah